cheers as hard as you can in a hot tub
welcome back to the Julian podcast ah is
your birthday in a couple days yeah if
you're watching this though my birthday
already happened first of all happy
birthday well thanks in retrospect
because it's all it's over thank you
back to reality now hmm I want to go
back to reality I hope you enjoyed your
weekend now I'm looking forward right
now to our weekend in Big Bear but I
hope you enjoyed it
thanks I hope I go too I hope you do too
Thanks I hope I do too I hope you do too
let's just not take the dogs let's just
go no you well oftentimes we'll take the
podcast completely off on one of our
birthdays because as we like plan out
the year for the podcast we we like
leave the birthdays and holidays slots
that we can take off you know to kind of
have like a rest that day but we're
podcasting during his birthday week
mm-hmm
so we decided to play a game of Amalur
go well also because we found time to do
it this week and we found a game well
yeah we are so we have we have this new
game that we wanted to try well cuz we
used to play that game on the podcast
called super fight and it was basically
like a card game where you draw cards
and the right it's like it's basically
if the argue redetermination write them
ourselves right it's a card game yeah
but so there's stuff on there and then
you have to argue your position as to
why your person would win or something
like that yeah but we wanted to make a
game called celebrity super fight we
have given I like that I like that name
celebrity super fun I think we should
call it celebrity super fight where we
have names in one and then obviously
card games are very fun but everything
is a lot funnier when you write them out
yourselves so we have made up some
abilities and or weapons and or things
like that that these people can have
Julian's going to draw
I'm gonna draw one we have to argue to
the death who the - about who's gonna
win we can take I think you know a
little bit of who the person is into
consideration when arguing the fight
honestly there's no rules let's just go
all the way out and then we'll have the
winners in one pile and you're like
you're winners in one pile and my
winners in another you know a winner's
battle the winner's bracket - then the
couple with the champion until come up
with the champion celebrity fighter okay
so half of half of the fighter is just a
real person in their name and then the
other half is a fictitious condition or
setup that they have had with weapons my
abilities yeah
are you good yeah I've been good ladies
first happy birthday can go first
this one is where the people are and I
folded them all up even though Julian
gets mad don't it's not your turn to
draw it's my turn well no we draw and
then we both read back to that oh that's
right okay
my turn to draw i like when they're
folded okay you go first all right round
one I have Jake Paul oh gosh already off
to a good start and let's see what his
ability is is fully covered in Vaseline
and has paid a hit man to fight for him
it's so cheap he had to just go and get
someone else to fight all right I have
Yoda boy or Mason Ramsey and he has a
piping hot hot pocket rocket launcher
while on rollerskates he's gonna get
killed by a hit man you think so I'm
supposed to fight for him aren't I yeah
you're supposed to fight for him well
here's the thing mmm-hmm it just says a
hit man mm-hmm
so it could be a low-grade Craigslist
hit men who maybe it isn't that good you
think they're a hit men on Craigslist I
don't know isn't there I got hit man
calm oh my god what are you gonna hit
man you get arrested for talking about
those oh my god
I don't know but Jake Paul found one
well from my extensive research research
into the show of Breaking Bad it's
pretty easy to get a hit man because
they're just lying around in that show
they're everywhere
are they really everyone's in touch with
one mmm they got a guy and I feel like
they get that guy from
probably similar to I'm not gonna say
that the websites name anymore because I
don't want them to like come for me like
a local posting like for sale type of
website you know and they're under the
facade of like being Baker's yeah it's
like it's like I think they're an
independent post office yeah they have
like a code word mm-hmm I baked muffin
tops but only when they're cold and then
they're like that's Oh cold muffin tops
wow that guy kills people there's gonna
buy a baked called muffin top nobody
that's how you know he's a hitman so
Jake Paul went through those specific
avenues he's got a guy to find this
person
so you're saying Jake Paul doesn't have
the money to hire a really good hit man
even if you want to get a good hit man
how do you do it mancom premium hit man
calm seriously like I get I get that
argument has only been debunking whether
or not Jay Paul has hired a got a got a
breakdown Jake Paul little-by-little
here cuz he's got a whole whole team
here he's got enough money to hire of
Nessie slit hitmen okay I have a
question what do you see Jay Paul as
being someone cerebral enough to not
[ __ ] that up in hiring a hitman I feel
like hiring a him in yes that sounds
easy and in theory but in practice
there's a lot of ways someone can [ __ ]
that I would argue that you could get an
undercover cop you could get in the bad
graces of the Hitman by being too
annoying and he'll kill you and steal
all your money like it's very rare that
someone just gets a him in there like
okay kill that guy he's like okay thank
you goodbye that's it like again from my
extensive research and Breaking Bad
never happens easily it really doesn't
sometimes the hit man's like hi I see
what you're offering me but now that I'm
in this situation let's see what's up
for grabs I would argue that Jake Paul
since he's hired a hitman who is if
you're a hitman I'm assuming you've
killed someone before right or you're of
rookie first time first time this is so
[ __ ]
how does a person become a hit men I
don't know you think someone but what
happens before that first kill are they
hidden
thank God I don't like thinking about
wait a minute hold on it's 2018 I think
he might hire a hit woman
okay that's fine what there's got to be
women for hired for kill so [ __ ] dark
lovely swallow and then look at me like
that all right can we get off the topic
actual let's just say no no no no let me
argue for once I guess we're assuming
that he hired a hitman which means he's
killed before I I don't think that a
child wearing roller skates wielding a
piping hot hot pocket runs
rocket launcher is gonna throw him off
and pay you a little picture we're
assuming it when I think of hitman I'm
assuming that person has a gun when
you're me paying a picture you're going
out you're the hitman that we know
yourself in the shoes of the killer okay
he's got his gun he's going towards the
old boy and all of a sudden he hears
this noise and it's the most beautiful
sound he's ever heard he's literally
never heard a yodel ever let alone what
this kid can do he's blown away he loses
control of his body he just drops his
gun he just stands there he's in awe
he's completely under the under the
spell of this kid hey bamm-bamm hot
pocket no they wouldn't explode explode
in melton
they would melt his skin then you know
boy comes up do you think hot pocket hot
enough to melt the skin to leave whoo
hops on him spider style grabs onto him
it goes really loud news here until his
whole head explodes
didn't I just paint that picture I think
I did I think you know boy wins that
fight ten out of ten times my guy is a
trained killer and has a gun and Jake
Paul's standing behind him everything
Vasily he's a trained killer killing
people who don't have a god-like voice
an ability to seduce you with that voice
just imagine someone yodeling as good as
him speed skating at you with a gun you
don't know that skate yeah it says he's
on roller skates
yeah that means maybe he's bad at roller
skating maybe me know maybe this is a
handicap for him because he can't
rollerskate there's not enough
information on there for you to come to
the conclusion that he can speed skate
on roller skates this is the first fight
okay yellow boy loses he gets shot in
the head by a sniper rifle from 800
meters out without even knowing what's
happening why did you just like fold
that fast I don't know I'm tired of
defending you little boy to be frank I
think you can be frank or to be I think
you made a really good argument and then
you you had me in for the kill and you
just gave up no you
I'll take the dub no honestly once we
got past the thought that Jay Paul would
successfully get a hit man who would not
kill Jake Paul then tree Paul's gonna
win that you need to take that back what
that is so [ __ ] up why is that [ __ ]
up no no I'm not saying I hit man okay
so say Jay Paul's like I want to get a
hit man to win this fight for me I'm not
saying the Hitman is gonna be like you
Jake Palmer to kill you oh my god it's
not like that it's like he wouldn't have
the necessary to he would have the
necessary like people's skills to deal
with the hit man delicately enough to
not piss the hit man off that something
is the hit man off yeah hit man has like
very notoriously quick tempers okay do
you want to do a whole pod casts on him
in you really enjoyed oh so I don't like
it I mean don't get me wrong I'll watch
Jason Bourne but like once we're talking
about somebody killing people I'm like
all right man there's much Breaking Bad
it's really educational I don't like it
we're gonna make it new you turn okay my
turn
James Charles has a blow dart gun and
rides a hoverboard oh [ __ ] damn that's
that's a multi-tasking all right I have
Julia Roberts please thank you scoffs
please
you're kidding me no you are kidding me
god I wish has a baseball bat and can
turn into Julia when she turns into
Julia really and I can't believe it
happened and we were joking like what if
Julia Roberts got the has a baseball bat
and can turn into Julia Roberts alright
so Hertz
so you're telling me your person
literally is carrying a piece of wood
and can turn into themselves yeah
they're not winning this fight James
Charles is gonna hoverboard up to that
Julia Roberts whether it's Julia 1 or
Julia 2 and blow your Sandra Bullock or
Anne Hathaway you mean dude it doesn't
matter Charles will huff and puff and
blow dart that Julia Roberts down like
the big bad wolf he is well yeah I don't
really know that will rain down upon
sorry like can we treat these as like
fights and not like someone's gonna die
like that's I think that's what's
bothering me is that it's meant to just
be a fight not like someone's gonna die
okay so this is just like an arena
everyone always walks out scotch freedom
yes exactly
do you remember a celebrity deathmatch
like that cartoon but they were like
claymation you're like Sarah God you
know quote unquote fighting to the death
egg it's fine this is safer advertisers
as well oh my god but like yeah it's
like a video game
yeah yes I was like no one's that this
is it's just a fictional fight I was
getting carried away also this was I was
getting carried away okay I was gonna
say that I don't know how helpful a
baseball bat would be against someone
that has a range weapon like a blow dart
since it but that's only if he's
accurate with that well if he it was
Ryan Higa level with that like [ __ ] you
were in trouble
Ryan Higa has a blow dart gun like in
his living room and anytime we come over
we were just picking up and Ike shoot
stuff with it's not actual blood arts
like little tiny tarts no it's just our
fun um but he's like really accurate
picture this you're James Charles hello
all of your people have noises see Julia
Roberts that's Julia Roberts alright
first try say he misses she's like oh
[ __ ] what happened Oh better get my
baseball bat turns into Julia Roberts
oh yeah morphs into herself she's
chasing him
he's like okay zooms back eight hundred
meters like how he has he has the
mobility in the range he's gonna win
this fight yeah I can't Jack Charles
wins
fight I can't argue that I really can't
sorry Julia Roberts turning into Julia
Roberts sorry an your turn
alright I have hmm
Conor McGregor mm-hmm off to a strong
start someone who we would save if we
didn't fold these up in you I'd like
folding them up no cuz I feel like if
Brandon mises and more and makes it
harder for you to just like I don't like
when you can see words you have to go in
there completely blind and just feel
around with your fingers Conor McGregor
can and will shove q-tips into your ear
canal and only moves by doing
handsprings
okay the handspring thing is pretty
accurate he does a lot of like flips and
handsprings
he doesn't do any flips he does hand
Springs he doesn't do hand Springs just
like car wheels
that's a cartwheel it's basically and
spring is very different it's very very
simple cartwheel is lateral a handspring
implies that you're moving like a front
handspring or backhand smooth Conor like
strung together a bunch of his his
cartwheels forward so he was a forward
cartwheel is like a front walkover
that's what he does
yeah for a walkover that's on a
handspring oh I cants because when your
feet and your hands aren't touching the
ground at the same time and a front
walkover your feet and your hands are
touching the ground at the same time
during two parts of that I don't have
time for this both when you start to
lose trivia and when you're finishing
the move REE Drummond she can she can
scream in sonic booms and is holding a
bowling ball but in the way only your
dad uses so the heaviest falling long
ugalla dad really we just screams to the
point where there's a sonic boom
every time she screams which by the way
would just kill her upon her right away
or win the fight no no sonic boom kill
you well if it's right on top of you
that's like a jet going sonic boom but
you're next to the jet like if she can
scream in sonic booms sorry the whole
arenas going down wait I actually want
to know the answer to that though like
if you're close enough to a sonic boom
would it kill you like you obviously can
a sonic boom kills
I read that yeah yeah wait would it kill
her as well is it like boom kill you if
you actually wanted to intentionally
kill someone with a sonic weapon there
isn't a whole lot of research on how you
would go about doing that the general
consensus is that allowed enough sound
could cause air air embolism in your
lungs which then travels to your heart
and kills you oh boy what it also killed
REE Drummond like she can do it one day
I think this is one of those fights with
wit we just both go down and then it's
like a draw no way this guy's doing
handsprings and end has a bunch of
q-tips he's gonna shove in your ear she
screams in sonic boom oh yeah try
shoving a q-tip in my ear here's 15
pounds of Dad ball he's losing it look
at matter
yeah you take away the q-tips you still
got a bowling ball this is a guy yeah
you win that one he can't fight someone
that screams sonic boom Congrats mr.
Reid drop me mrs. Reid room mrs. MS is
she married yeah still I don't know the
answer
mrs. REE Drummond okay how about just
read Ramat how about mr. miss Drummond's
in your ether it's dead it's dead
Andrew hurt her only in the formal you
said okay who's dead that's good oh my
hands still in there okay you go first
all right
I have Trey who has a basketball game
tomorrow and his ability is he's an
infant form and can shoot table salt
spider-man style out of his wrists hi my
name is drag a basketball game tomorrow
[ __ ] salt out of my wrists whoever
you're fighting is technically fighting
well it's Guy Fieri classy fights
infants has 30 ninja stars but can only
lob them southpaw style and then when
they land their grenades he is
destroying Trey the infant okay here's
my argument here's my argument okay I
have a small window dog you guys guy
fieri loves one thing and one thing only
food
oh no no this salt goes in the guy's
mouth and then he's in capacity although
Trey does not have the ability to beat
Guy Fieri he does have the ability to
incapacitate him which then beats Guy
Fieri Guy Fieri beats Guy Fieri not Trey
but he will throw salt into his mouth so
much that he is so full of salt that
it's so delicious
Guy Fieri dice not dice guys in the in
the match real-life loser loses the
match dude honestly I wanted to defend
this but the thought of Guy Fieri were
refusing salt or salty foods is that's
what he's about he's gonna get a little
taste of that salt like one grain is
gonna find his way into his Guy Fieri
mouth mm-hmm his eyes are gonna light up
he's gonna think of all the Triple D
restaurants he's bent and his favorite
ones are gonna pop to the front of his
head while he's just gonna go into a
state of what is he gonna go into a
state oh just be standing there thinking
how food that's it mm-hmm he's gonna
drop all the ninja stars and they're all
gonna exploded his feet yeah big done
Thank You Trey hey what you didn't need
to rip that up and then sprinkle it on
the table or wanted to okay my name is
PewDiePie and I only have a butter knife
but on every odd minute I released tear
gas farts so like literally every 60
seconds is he affected by the tear gas
or no probably not
he's immune to the tear he's affected by
the tear gas just as much as someone
would be affected by their own farts a
little bit but he's laughing the whole
time yeah he's enjoying your gas by the
way tear gas better have some good okay
I have Ricky Dillon K a youtuber
showdown ready okay it's vlogging the
fight but their vlog camera shoots bb's
so you have a couple of shots yes like
guys okay what are you hoping to happen
before you choke and die
theoretically well I mean Ricky Dylan's
winning no matter what because he's
vlogging this fight so he's the winner
no matter didn't happen I mean I would
like to see a video of PewDiePie farting
out tear gas what is he looking for what
is that good that's his weapon but what
is he gonna do with it cuz even so if
you were to say a guy has a butter knife
a guy has a vlog camera the blog camera
guy even if it's just a normal camera
can can win that fight yeah a butter
knife yeah he's gonna slice pretty much
a waste of your tongue
saw you really slowly and just sort of
maybe more bash you over the head with a
vlog camera but he has BB guns in it or
BB bullets BB's he's got some big piece
what happens when Ricky smells tear gas
and starts crying and peeing and stuff
coming out of the tear gas is crazy I
don't know I've never tried to your gas
I don't think one tries I don't I'm just
saying I don't have any first-hand
experience with tear gas no boy like it
would be not only would tear gas make
him cry but once the tears started
flowing Rick he's like hey I'm vlogging
just keep on the waterworks you know
build it up as some dramatic video he's
just gonna be crying and then as he's
crying his vision gets blurred PewDiePie
grabs that butter knife and runs full
force all the way from England and just
pokes rich I don't think that PewDiePie
has the ability to win this fight why
because he can he can make it so Ricky
can't fight but can he finish him okay I
pretty sure okay in a normal fight
PewDiePie vs. Ricky Dillon I don't know
who would win that I don't know I got to
see them matched up I got to see the
tale of the tape where they stack up
against each other I don't know yeah the
height the reach the weight all that I
need to see that but if I'm just like
estimating anyone who's just like crying
and peeing and
[Laughter]
I'm fine I don't think they can fight I
think here I think once Ricky goes down
from that tear gas that's kind of over
yeah
but then also so is everybody like
around yeah nobody wins thanks a lot
Felix alright but he won he won I have
Nicolas Cage mm-hmm
he's not good at fighting but he's
driving a car he's not good at fighting
but he's driving a car that's gonna be
hard to beat on you over it's the worst
fighter ever he doesn't need a fight to
drive if it's like in a boxing ring he's
gonna have to be really crap okay he's
fighting Cher okay
are you ready yeah has poison liquid
lipstick that when comes in contact with
another person kills them
so she's she's got a literally kiss her
yes she has to kiss her enemy he's
driving around in his Ford GT ready to
just paint it red where did you come up
with Ford GT that's the car that Nicolas
Cage drives don't you know that no how
do you know that cuz I've looked up
Nicolas Cage was he driving it like in
national treasure or something is he
driving it in the Wicker Man how'd it
get burned how to get burned how to get
burned after that movie he used his
money that he won or earned to buy that
okay after your personal ad okay um
Nicolas Cage wins yeah no I can't argue
you're saying a deadly kiss has to beat
a car yes sure needs to be in contact
with a person in order to have a chance
of winning unless Nick's just hammered
okay and he crashes the car
let me opps in the passenger seat let me
paint a scenario where she could win her
she's share there was she's beautiful
she's very persuasive nick is driving he
sees a leg like this
come on Nicolas Cage can't resist a
lady's leg he sees it gets distracted
says hey how you doing she leans and
kisses giant hole in your argument [ __ ]
the only contact I've ever seen him have
with a female was that movie where he
punched her so if anything he's just
getting more angry when he sees her legs
oh my god it is so not true
the only contact he's ever had with what
are you talking about in movies I've
only watched that movie I've seen a
ghostwriter
but he doesn't punch a woman in
ghostwriter he only punches the wall
what's that movie I don't know what
movie that is why should I google it
what movie does Nic Cage punch a girl in
sure Julian what movie does Nicolas
punch I can't argue this like obviously
he's gonna win he's driving a car
punches a woman while wearing a bear
suit wait the Wicker Man is it the
Wicker Man
maybe punch Nicolas Cage punches Kathy
Bates thank you for watching that clip
out of context it's so bizarre people
without anything yeah
like for those of you that think that
Julian's laughing at Nick Cage not
laughing at punching in one manager yeah
it's not that it's a snit cage means
that he has a [ __ ] car yeah he really
does by sure alright I got DJ Khaled
alright showed up in centaur form with
baseball cleats and is holding a lit
roman candle a centaur imagine a horse
with baseball cleats mm-hmm you are far
mm-hmm good luck to anybody around them
Taylor Swift is on Brock Lesnar's
shoulders wielding an entire tanning bed
hey how is she carrying that tanning bed
she cannot carry a tanning
nobody can carry it anymore that's not
true carry it there's strong men yeah
but think I'd like pick it up can they
carry it it is not seen strongman
competitions they can carry trucks they
can carry like giant LED balls I think
you told they can pull trucks what about
the ball that they lift yeah if it's
shaped like a ball they can put their
arms around you I would argue that it's
easier to lift you put you put it the
tanning bed up on its side and then you
like double leg it and put it on your
shoulder it's gonna be fireman's carry
that thing it's easy you just can't wrap
your arms around a tanning bed have you
seen some of these throws they have 40
feet arms no um regardless she's Barrett
she's holding the the bed mm-hmm I'm
sorry but you're gonna lose just singing
carrying this bed and then don't look at
mine DJ handle DJ Khaled is wearing
baseball cleats as a second if you strip
away the roman candle first in the
tanning bed you have dj khaled as the
Centaur that versus anything wins okay
I'm losing I'm putting down my name yes
congrats on that win there's no way I'm
winning that Jesus no way you first okay
I have Papa John this is her that he
says something racist oh my god has
special thurible item that when deployed
makes the target instantly burst into
doing alive musically oh oh that's a
good that's a good power I don't know
how you're gonna finish a fight like
that while they're doing the musically
they're just like you just come up then
just punch him right then alright in the
job hmm you could finish that with their
job no Jeffrey star is hammered drunk
and wielding a dirty just cooked with
cast iron pan uh well he's drunk so he
doesn't even drink oh man this turned
out bad what do you think he just cooked
I don't know maybe his last enemy oh my
god I think
and is literally better than no weapon
at all yeah Papa John doesn't have a
weapon and dude Papa John D don't don't
run up on me like that dude Jeffrey so
we did we'd kill that musically so yeah
he would destroy musically yeah every
star wits by Papa
yeah there's no way Papa John no sugar
by there's no way Papa John can win that
what you got okay I have shane dawson
what does he do
oh boy has a hacked puppet he has a
hacked poppet that now fires 762 ammo
out of the end of it every time he bops
it twists it or pulls it on beat I have
a Elon Musk who can summon Rick Astley
as the distraction as they attack with
their sword and shield so we're talking
about a sword and shield versus 762 in a
Bapat and we all know Shane would
absolutely kill Baba pyth stop it twist
it pull it
twist it again pop it pop it but Elon
Musk can block those with his shield he
can block 762 rifle ammo you don't know
what kind of shield it is okay it's like
a Captain America shield why are you
arguing for me I'm just saying
sword and shield I would heart I would
hardly believe a sword is paired with
the Captain America shield what does he
have like a metal shield that they used
back in the medieval time what's his
weapon though just like his good heart a
sword no Captain America no he's yeah
he's like very strong and he's I don't
he just got his shield in like he throws
the shield like a boomerang and kills
people it's very strong looks like very
like how do you know Elon Musk doesn't
have one of those he stole it he could
probably steal Captain America's shield
fine take the loss
well let me say this so if Shane Dawson
he has the limitation that he has to do
it only shoots on everyone
a single-shot rifle ah but he has to be
like in between sit like you could block
and then he could strike with his sword
in the middle when he's a while she's
trying to his sword twisting long sword
drawn his sword
yeah but he's blocking the shots and
then it goes in for a stab
yeah well is e1 fast enough to to make
that oh and also he has Rick Astley
Shane would be looking at Rick Astley I
mean like why is Rick Astley here and
then just dead I think Elin wins this
yeah I can't decide for you on wins this
hack bapat is pretty cool though shane
bops at once fires a bullet he's going
to twist again all of a sudden never
gonna give you up off to his left
it's not a video it's him himself it's
Rick Astley he's singing real loud he's
twisting it he's offbeat he's like wait
I was distracted there's another beat
over there that's another beat Rick
Astley's beat okay this is a fatal error
shame dude that is like the most
powerful Rick Astley would be in any
fight against that you're throwing off
his [ __ ] rhythm you can't concentrate
it enough to BOP it if you're also
listening to Assam congrats on winning
you're only putting your winners here
right mm-hmm
I only have three winners I have Oprah
mm-hmm and Oprah's ability is has a
revolver but is writing to dolphins
demands to fight you underwater why is
she so demanding about that cuz she's
Oprah fair enough
Matt Damon in a wheelchair offensively
by choice and also has a sniper sniper
rifle what the hell so he can fight he's
not even impaired he's not even disabled
he's just in a wheelchair and people are
telling him to get out he's making like
wheelchair jokes offensively yeah he's
just like being in a wheelchair people
don't like get out of that wheelchair
Matt Damon and he's like no does that
mean anyone who's in a wheelchair that
doesn't physically need to be as being
offensive no he's being offensive
so he's offending people
he's not even stop offending people he's
offensive with disabilities and he also
is a sniper rifle
I mean Matt Damon we know can snipe that
guy is literally but even if over I'm
never bored
even if Oprah's underwater he could
still snipe her right
hmm depends on the ammo and the
trajectory in the distance and the yeah
he'll kill he'll tell anybody he's Jason
[ __ ] born are you kidding me oh sorry
Oprah you have a revolver yeah she in
the Wild West with that oh good luck
trying to get Jason Bourne to fight you
were in her water I mean go for you
where the [ __ ] he wants the show does
have dolphins so they'll probably put
her in a good position they're smart
they know what's going on and they can
use echolocation what is she just like
diving up and down gun doesn't work once
it's wet it's like it's soaked and
jammed she's just in the water with
dolphins a fatal flaw okay Matt Damon
wins Congrats mr. Bourne yeah oh wait
we're missing one what's this one that
was one oh this is one that I already
did
well what is it Cesar Millan
yeah carries five brow pencils all sharp
until you lose against everyone all
right so now winner's bracket so let's
match these up how do we match them up
we don't we just choose a winner let's
just choose the winner mm-hmm okay all
right so let's weed out the losers for
sure
okay the I think hammer Geoffrey start
with a pan dude
he's facing a car he's facing a blow
dart he's facing like get out I agree
good run Geoffrey I would also say that
Trey who has a basketball game tomorrow
is an infant form and can shoot table
salt spider-man style out of one victory
against guys yeah I think he's Pete yeah
hey he took guy very out of game so you
did good for him he did butter-knife
Felix he has tear gas farts every other
minute though there's 60 seconds where
he's standing there like an idiot with a
dull knife someone could attack in that
60 second especially a car I feel like
Nick Cage is gonna win
he's driving in circles like at 100
miles an hour just doing it Sookie
you can't lose you as a caller it's okay
his cars so loud he isn't here rick
astley so Elon Musk is out his sword and
shield I mean oh yeah totally
okay REE Drummond she's holding a
bowling ball she's probably a she just
thought she can scream sonic booms
though that could beat a car can it
because he's in a car so he's protected
like a little bit from sound and also
like sonic boom oh yeah shatters the
glass he is glass protection everyone
else dies oh so he hears one sonic boom
Shh adders he knows exactly what it's
really mmm Nic Cage kills me I think
Reed REE Drummond I mean I think Nic
Cage is like an easy win here he's not
good at fighting yeah James Charles
could kill him with a blow dart gun he
has to have a hell of a shot yeah it
would be it's a fast moving target I
don't think he's got that DJ Khaled even
though he's a centaur and he has
Cleveland yeah by a car he could light
off his one roman candle towards him to
distract him but after that scheme Oh a
centaurs not gonna be there not know his
legs are gonna get and certainly not
Jake Paul with a hitman well Jake
no well Jake Paul paid a hitman for one
kill and he got that one kill to get to
this round yeah yeah now Jake Paul is
just gonna be standing there and amongst
all these people move weapons okay James
Charles sorry
that's no right what about Matt Damon
with a rifle being at a wheelchair
though he can't like climb up places
he's decided to be in a wheelchair
even though people are demanding that he
stopped doing that because it's
offensive yeah like he clearly doesn't
give a [ __ ] about what people think at
this point yeah he's he's gonna get hit
by a car he's gonna get me drunk dude
our winner I think we have our winner
Nikolas [ __ ] cage who is not
good at fighting but is driving a car
wins the celebrity super Veidt round one
join us next week for round two where we
do it all for real
no no no we're not gonna do it all for
real this is all make-believe if I upset
you I'm sorry junk I can't believe that
after all the people that we we were
like when we were making these we're
like okay we need to give them a weapon
and then maybe give them a limitation or
something that's like you know a little
different that makes it a little weirder
you know in a car one and we just give
Nic Cage a car well we didn't give them
a cage a car we gave you a cage just
freakin stole it I can't believe Julia
Roberts got the Julia Roberts card man
that's pretty great well this was
definitely more fun than both super
fight and nuclear winter I think this is
more fun because it's just fighting it
is you know well congrats in a cage guys
send your love on Twitter just tell him
congrats for winning the Super fight in
a car hey a winners a winner don't be a
sore loser he's driving off to victory
right now oh my god the grenades
somebody has Brittnay somebody has ninja
stars that land in turn into grenades
but they have to lob them softball style
like it's a slow pitch you know good
luck have you ever tried to blow up a
car in pump G with a grenade yeah it's
[ __ ] hard really hard imagine only
having no oh man I can't believe Nicolas
Cage won I can why he'll do whatever it
takes to win he punched a woman in a
movie because it was a job and it was in
the script and in the role he did it
it's a fake its fake really think could
see the whole thing and I don't even
remember the part of the plot line in
which it was happening he was versus
Kathy Bates and he walked up to her very
slowly and then punched it with his hand
it's been so long since I've seen that
movie have you ever seen have you ever
seen that movie
no I I've listened to the audiobook but
I've never seen no you have not yeah
look at me like that you have not
listened to the Wickerman audio buzz no
audio
it's just a movie alright well that was
fun that was fun hopefully you guys
enjoyed it let us know if he wants to do
skin we we very easily foresee apart 2/3
for this series I think this could right
we need more celebrity fights to happen
do we need them comment below also
comment below happy birthday to Jenna
even though her birthday was Saturday
for you and it's over it's never over
it's always your birthday oh that's
sweet but it's literally not I hope you
have a good forever birthday today and
always oh thanks
pop it twist it pull it it's like that
vine pop it
Twiggy makes all the noises to them yeah
alright guys well have a great week
we'll see you next time on the Jim Julie
podcast and this is all for pretend
[Music]
[Music]